well Jimmy Johnson found out he was
going into the Hall of Fame live on TV
the NFL on Fox analyst joining us on the
program Jimmy good morning
congratulations I got a feeling Terry
Bradshaw's not good at keeping secrets
duh did you get any idea that this was
going to happen live on TV
Danny no it was a shock to all of us
because you know Jerry none of the guys
knew our producer knew he told me later
on but he didn't let any of us know and
you know I thought that there was a
chance that I was going to get in but I
didn't anticipate this I've been there
and a half time my mind was racing I was
already to do half time and talk about
the coverage that Seattle had against
Green Bay and stuff and all of a sudden
Dave Baker walks out and I was in shock
you know and and I think all of our
other guys were too and you know they
were as excited as I was you know it was
really a great moment and Troy Aikman
was in the broadcast booth and over
overwhelmed by I think he cried as much
as you did well you know I was put into
the College Football Hall of Fame but I
was seven or eight years ago and you
know that was obviously special because
I coached in college for a long time but
but this this was really something
because people don't realize you know
the cowboy Tom Landry is one the
greatest coaches that it's ever been but
they had three losing seasons in a row
and they were three and thirteen when we
went to the Cowboys I mean it really the
the cupboard was bare and and to take
the team from one in 15 to four straight
losing seasons and to win back-to-back
Super Bowls was quite an accomplishment
you know and and I'm not saying for me
I'm talking about my assistant coaches
you know the north
Turner's the day once it's a tony wise
you know you know really you know the
the guys that that helped me and and
then all the great players that we ended
up having with the Cowboys it was it was
a quite an accomplishment and it was
nice to be recognized for that when you
first started out with the Cowboys and
he went though through those lean years
did you ever think that you were in
jeopardy of being fired
I oh no I mean I first of all I had a 10
year contract but but you know you know
I guess we were so naive
you know we went three and one in
pre-season we didn't realize how bad we
were but of course we were trying to win
every game at pre-season I was a college
coach I didn't know I thought you're
supposed to win this preseason games and
and we had had so much success you know
we only lost like you know two regular
season games and four years coming from
the University of Miami so we were so
naive we were think we're just gonna
walk into the NFL just start beating
everybody well it doesn't work that way
especially when you don't have a lot of
talent on your team and and so I mean I
think that's the biggest thing is that
you know we were very confident that we
were going to win I actually told the
guys during that 1 in 15 year I took you
know my my inner circle crew you know
when you launched it and you know Butch
Davis and temple and you know North and
all of them I said listen guys I said
you know I told you we're gonna win a
national championship you know when we
were together at Oklahoma State we won
that national championship at Miami I
said hang with me we're gonna win us a
Super Bowl eventually and it eventually
happened what don't I know about the
Herschel Walker tree you know it would
take me 30 minutes to explain it and
nobody really still to this day
understands it because everybody thinks
that we've got you know we got like 15
players out of this thing you know
actually you know Ernie Accorsi was at
the Cleveland Browns you know I was on
the phone every day trying to trade
anybody I had that those first couple
years because I knew I knew if it was
the old you know take the best player
available like the NFL did nobody traded
back then there was no fantasy football
and if we take the best player available
we weren't going to do anything but we
weren't going to turn this thing around
because we didn't have enough players
and the only thing I could do is try to
make some trades you know
to build up some draft picks and so I
tried to trade Steve Walsh to a bunch of
teams I ended up trading him for one two
and a three to New Orleans but I'd been
on the phone with Minnesota Vikings with
my clan trying to trade Steve Walsh but
Ernie Accorsi was with the Cleveland
Browns and he called he said what would
it take to get Herschel Walker he's your
only Pro Bowl player everybody kind of
looked at your only player and I said
well you know it's going to be one of
those guy Lombardo's
you know Lombardo you know I come on the
tuba 300 to go three and so he called
back and he said we don't have a 1 next
year and they duh-duh-duh
and so he said what about this he said I
said you know that may that may work he
said well I'll have Art Modell call you
tonight and we'll finalize this thing
and so I went to Jerry I said Jerry I
said I've got a hell of a trade I said
but I think you know maybe we can get
better and you know we might as well
investigated I said you know Rincon
Smith you know Herschel's from Georgia
why don't you call him Atlanta I'm gonna
call you know a bunch of these other
teams and I called Minnesota called Mike
Lynn so I went to practice and then I
came out back at practice and my
secretary said there's a fax on your
deal about what Mike Lynn wants to offer
for Herschel Walker and we were so bad
he wanted to give me five players that
were cast off for him one had you know
bad knee one was disgruntled but they
were all better than anything we had you
know and and he said you know if you
keep these players you know the only
thing you only pick you get you get the
one first-round pick that's it yeah
three years from now if you keep these
players and ever player doesn't make it
or you don't keep this player you end up
getting a pic that's corresponds you
know to you is his name well right then
and there I knew I was going to keep in
those players I knew I was going to get
picks but I couldn't tell Mike that so I
anticipated down the road releasing
those players and getting the picks and
then I got to thank it well I've got him
in a bind you know I you know if I wait
until the end of season
I can negotiate a mr. tillens I'm going
to cut all these players so you're not
gonna get anything I said let me keep
the players and two picks and I'll kick
you back a three or seven or something
and so we've released one right off the
bat one had a bad attitude we've
released him
we ended up negotiating and none of
those players were part of our Super
Bowl teams but but we were able to keep
three of those players and I'm getting
four or five picks so we ended up about
five players out of that deal but no one
really understood the trade and and how
it worked and like I said a lot of
people don't understand it to this day
if you don't make that trade Oh Dan
that was one trade like I said back then
teams didn't trade like for instance the
New York Giants made one trade in five
years that was with me in five years I
made 51 trades and those 51 trades were
more than the entire league put together
and that's when I came up with the value
chart of trading picks for picks because
I wanted a value right there in front of
me on draft day and it's saying hey I'll
I'll swap twos and I'll throw you you
know my for well they're on the clock
they don't know what the value is and
they say okay but I had the chart right
in front of me so I knew what the
relative value was the only saying now
every T fact I talked to how's he knew
some the other day he said hey I use
your chart on the Peters trade with the
rams so everybody in the league's got
the job after I lost all my coaches you
know when Wanstead goes to Chicago and
North goes to Washington where they took
the chart with them so everybody had the
chart we got to call it a Johnson chart
no well yeah that's your legacy it
really is well did the chart helped me
but but we made you know we made a you
know trading for Charles Haley probably
put us in the Super Bowl mmm you know
John John McVay you know Colin said hey
you know I've got a great player but he
can't get along with our coach
you know would you be interested and so
I had my coaches call their coaches my
players call their players well what
kind of guys told Haley and they all
said hey he's a great player he's smart
you know but you know he has a little
problem with authority you know and I
said you know if he's smart and he's got
passion for the game and he works hard I
can deal with that so we ended up making
a trade and that was a key for us you
know getting that pass rush you know for
our team you know and we lose we lose in
the third year we lose in the playoffs
we beat Chicago and then we lose a
Detroit because we didn't have any
defensive backs well the next year I
Drive
Darren Woodson and Kevin Smith you know
to help our defensive backs and so we
kind of lock thing and that's when we
had to Haley trade I put us in a couple
of Super Bowls but we made 51 trades
like I said Pete James didn't trade back
then he's Jimmie Johnson now Hall of
Famer and if Ellen Fox analyst can you
clear something up with your first job
was that at Louisiana Tech and did you
recruit Terry Bradshaw to Louisiana Tech
I watched him play I remember sitting in
the stadium with a coat the assistant
coach that was assigned to him was EJ
Lewis our secondary coach at Louisiana
Tech that was that was my first coaching
job and I wasn't actively recruiting him
but I watched him play his senior year
in high school at Woodlawn high school
and so that was really my first contact
with him but I really did know him and
didn't actually recruit him but I was I
was with the coach that was involved in
recruiting him for Louisiana Tech of all
the teams this weekend coming up who do
you think has the best chance of pulling
off the surprise on the road well yeah I
think both of them have a shot the other
way it might be able you know it's got
to be recognized as doing one of the
best coaching jobs in the league this
year I mean making that decision to put
Tannehill in there and make a change at
quarterback you know they are a physical
football team and they
you know they've got a horse back there
running the football and so they can
play keep-away with you running the
football and Tannehill is played well
and they are very efficient they don't
make a lot of mistakes he comes from the
Bill Belichick line so you know he knows
how to get it done
I give him a chance as good as Kansas
City is and as many points as they score
I give them a chance and and Green Bay
got beat you know thirty seven to eight
out there a few weeks ago against San
Francisco but when you got Aaron Rodgers
and you got Aaron Jones it can run the
ball and your defense has played great
here the last month or so even though
they got beat the last time out there I
don't discount them did you I don't know
if you still stay in touch with that
order on who was I think your defensive
line coach yep hey hey listen listen to
this coach he said you know I'm of
course you know you know once that and
Butch Davis and Campo and and those guys
but my my intern coaches my young guys
coming up was you know Chuck Pagano ed
or Geron Tommy Tuberville Bill Johnson
who is a defensive line coach I think
with the Saints where he was with the
Saints and the Rams I mean yeah I had
some quality coaches or Geron did a
great job for me did you understand what
he was saying I mean did he have that
voice back then he's got that gravelly
bow oh my gosh I think that's a coach's
voice there and you know what though
he's a great recruiter he's a great
person he's so sincere the players love
him the mothers and daddies when he
recruits players they love him and he
went through tough times now I mean
there you can look at his history and
there were some times that he was on the
edge but he's overcome those things and
and it just doing a great job at LSU and
so proud of him you know we've talked to
time or two in fact
this morning how proud I was of him well
congrats on the honor it was wonderful
to see and thank you for telling stories
we always appreciate that Jimmy and have
fun this weekend all right Dan I
certainly appreciate it
that's Jimmy Johnson Hall of Famer for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]